[Music]
i'm andrew sandberg i'm a senior
research fellow
at the future of humanity institute at
oxford university
and my day job is about thinking about
the ethics and social impact of human
enhancement
global catastrophic risks and the
long-term future of humanity
as well as how to think well about these
very uncertain topics
andes thank you for joining us we're
going to talk a little bit about
transhumanism
at the moment um i guess we'll start
with
what is transhumanism so you can define
transumers in several different ways
one way is saying it's about thinking
that the human condition is good but
could be better
and we can actually try to fix this
using technology
another way of explaining it is to say
this is a continuation of the classical
humanist idea about improving the human
condition in various ways
through the enlightenment ideas about
using
science then through the industrial
revolution onward
so here it's a strand of thought there
are particular thinkers associated with
it
starting maybe somewhat with aj wells
definitely
with haldane and bernal and then going
forward to modern thinkers
another way of saying is well being
human could be more fun
we could be smarter we could live longer
we could maybe be wiser could we find
ways of improving this
not just by reading good books and
debating but also maybe fixing our genes
well in in that case um where do you fit
in
and what is the relationship um
contemporary between
um this ideation stage to people like hd
well through literature and art
and actioning it through science through
biotechnology for example
so it's not a coincidence that a.g wells
is quite often mentioned because besides
being a science fiction author he
actually was one of the founders of
future studies
he seriously proposed that we should
have professors of prognostication or
professors of the future
and that we should scientifically try to
say something sensible about the future
so it could steer towards good futures
in a better way
and in many ways various ways back and
forth so the science fiction stories
inspire people to become scientists and
engineers
countless people have said that they
wanted to become scientists of the
reading science fiction
and making some of the ideas in science
fiction real
and then of course many scientists are
seeing these inventions
and come up with other interesting ideas
that science fiction offers bring up
so for example freeman dyson is
among other things famous for because of
dyson spheres covering an entire star
with solar connectors
he wrote a series paper about this in
the 1960s but as he likes to point out
the idea was of course in all of
stapleton's novel star maker from the
1930s
but only a year after dyson wrote his
paper science fiction i was using the
concept showed up and a lot of people's
understanding
about because it come from a science
fiction novels then inspiring scientists
to do searches for actual
spheres out in the universe so there is
a back and forth between
ideas fiction and visions and actual
research
are there any ideas in in literature
popular or not that
you would like to see in the short term
future
so in the short term future i think we
want to have human enhancement that
works well
it's a horrible shame that people are
aging and dying unnecessarily
we could be smarter we could have better
ways of handling our mental language
and we need other technologies like in
ai safety technology
to make our machines safer and better
and of course science fiction is full of
ideas that
if implemented would change the future
of humanity in that various ways
but some of them are going to take a
long while to implement them the
ordering might matter
so long term obviously we need to go to
space
as uh ziokovsky put it the earth is a
cradle of
mankind but you don't live in your
cradle forever
however maybe we want to fix some things
on earth before going to space
even though again it's complicated
because the technology would need to
colonize mars
it would involve autonomous greenhouses
that can work in a super arid
environment
ways of extracting resources without
having good ore bodies
and really renewable energy sources
which all sounds like something we might
want on earth first
so the amazing thing is it's easy to
motivate people to do research about
this when it comes to space
harder actually to get research grants
when saying oh this is going to help
sub-saharan
africa so there is also this weird thing
about our motivations quite often we get
more strongly motivated by utopian
visions and the stories
than many of the pressing problems but
ideally we then turn from the fiction
into actually
doing something about the problems i
will come to the specifics of the
problems in a second
but on that final point between uh that
you made
on uh funding in relation to utopian
almost idealized scientific ideas
how do we change that how do we make
sure
that funding goes to those who need it
most whether that's
material analysis or a structural change
in the way that we approach funding in
science
so the big problem in funding and
science is that it's extremely
cumbersome right now
so most academics will complain about
that they spend far too much time
writing grants or reporting about grants
when actually doing the research
but deeper the problem is that many of
your grant bodies they certainly want to
support
excellent research that produce good
outcomes but they tend to give to things
that are established that they know
is not going to be wasted because the
worst thing that could happen to a
grandfather
is accusations that they're wasting
public money
the problem is of course that means that
interdisciplinary research is not going
to get very supported
even if it's excellent it doesn't fit
neatly into
the ways we organize grants also another
problem is that
many important questions are under
research and neglected
we don't know much about them yet so
actually investigating them is a
relatively cheap way of actually
gaining quite a lot of knowledge so
putting money into well-established
fields
means that we're actually missing out on
a lot of knowledge production
so in my ideal world we would probably
put a lot more
grants into random topics that could be
important but we don't know yet
and checking even though a cursory check
might tell you quite a bit about
where it might be worth doing more and
you might also want to work more on the
interdisciplinaries
which is hard so it might be that
sometimes we're just over complicating
things and maybe we should just
randomize the whole grant process
are there any specific examples to mind
of random areas of research that you
would like
funding put into so probably
give me five minutes i can probably
think up a very very long list
but in many cases it's going to be
unusual
topics or side topics or things that
people have not been investigating very
much
very for example in neuroscience very
question about
how do you get stable representations i
think that's actually an extremely
important question yet
very few people seem to be investigating
it when it comes to drugs
it's fairly well known that most
drugs that people take that have mental
effects
tend to cause habituation of various
kinds yet we don't argue much about
habituation
to drugs we take for high blood pressure
why is that
and why does it seem that all the drugs
that are said to have habituation
seem to be drugs that are controlled
rather than medical drugs
there might be something worth
investigating there but i think there's
thousands of millions of topics like
that that have not been properly
investigated because we're low status
because people don't seem important
so one approach might be to say what is
big in life
what matters a lot we should perhaps put
in a commensurate amount of research
so a third of our life is spent sleep
yet we don't spend that much work on
sleep research
and currently our sleep aids are really
atrociously bad
sleeping pills yup they make you
unconscious but they don't make you very
rested
we need better ways of sleeping if we
could improve sleep quality
we would win quite a bit i would argue
that
aging is another thing that is unduly
neglected people recognize that the
illnesses and chronic diseases
of aging are important yet doing
something about the course
might actually be much more effective
and would save both individuals and
society from a lot of pain and loss
yet that is again fairly neglected
are there any concerns you have about
developing technologies that may be well
intended
maybe biotech as an example um to
improve humanity in the future of
humanity are there any concerns about
how they could go wrong
things are always going wrong you can't
develop a new technology without people
figuring out how to misuse it so the
sensible thing is to think about
what can we do about that to actually
get some decent results out of this
and this is where transhumanism is
interesting because it actually takes
many of the radical possibilities
seriously if you think
machine learning and ai is never really
going to do anything
then you're not going to be that worried
about ai safety because well the robots
are never going to
climb stairs anyway if you on the other
hand think that maybe we could actually
get machines smarter than humans and
they could
undergo a technological singularity that
changes the whole future uh-oh
you better make sure they have the right
values that you're programming safely
so it's actually worth noticing how
transhumas were kind of instrumental in
developing the field of ai safety in the
light in the late 90s
the field of air research had been
around since the 50s
but concerns about safety had mostly
about industrial robots not squishing
people
it only took until very recently before
people started realizing
actually there might be problems maybe
it's not necessarily apocalyptic risk
but
algorithmic bias is actually worth
dealing with we are actually having
various
issues when robots become powerful like
we see with drone strikes
even though that's not autonomous
systems that's still a way of automating
or
tele-extending humans in a way that's
morally problematic
so the transhumanist interest in being
fairly concrete about could we do
interesting things with this and its
willingness to think about visions
also means that you can play around with
the dark side so
william gibson's neuromancer might be
well known as
the cyberpunk novel but it's worth
noticing bruce sterling's
shish matrix which came out about the
same time which is also equally
instrumental in creating the cyberpunk
movement
that's essentially set in a
transhumanist future and it's not
necessarily a nice
future because humanity has branched out
in a lot of very different subspecies
and they're all competing against each
other it's a very interesting story
because
here it's not within so much of a nitty
gritty and neon lit streets
of rain rainy tokyo but here you're out
in space and you have different
political factions undergoing the
battles that you get between political
factions
and you get other risks and dangers so
these
aspects are very much part of a
transhumanist content of thinking about
it
of course many transhumanists would just
say oh yeah we're probably going to
solve that
the more serious ones who actually want
to think about and do something
would say actually how do we avoid some
of the obvious downsides
and then you can do a tertiary thinking
we will never be able to figure out all
the risks beforehand can we actually
handle
risk in a better way again it's not a
coincidence that trans humans have been
involved in the work on existential risk
because if you think that the future
could potentially be radically better or
different from the present
it could perhaps be radically different
and worse than the present including
that we all go extinct because advanced
technology
so again it's not a question that trans
humans are actually quite keen on
thinking about the end of the world
and how to stop that so putting aside
that risk which we can't predict until
it arises
those which we can um are there
regulations
in place in the industries in which
transhumanisms are interested
transhumanists rather are interested in
developing
are there regulations in place to
mitigate the risks
say of ai stay off nanotechnology
so so when it comes to artificial
intelligence i think there's a slow
moment towards realizing we need to take
safety and ethics
seriously one might argue whether that's
done in the right way
right now most of the thinking is done
inside the industry and academia and it
might mostly
self-regulation which might be a
sensible thing because it's so early
days that it's actually very unclear
what laws you might want to politicians
to make
what the regulator should actually exist
we need to figure out more about what
we're doing here
but we should be mindful that we're not
spending all the time talking about the
ethics
and what we might want to know before we
actually get to dangerous territory
when it comes to nanotechnology the
problem was that much of a pro
radical problem is of nanotechnology in
the 90s then
got sidetracked by investigation into
material science and
although there was interesting concerns
about nanoparticles and being careful
about
not causing a new form of environmental
pollutant
much of the mainstream work did not
pursue the radical vision of
nanotechnology
which again meant that there has not
been much safety thinking about that
that might change as people actually
demonstrate the real applications
biotechnology is another good example
where we actually do have institutional
systems
that are fairly workable for many of the
more traditional forms of biological
research
and the development when it comes to
biosafety we know
somewhat the problem is biohacking that
doesn't naturally fit in
to that world and we are probably going
to see an application biotechnology that
are very much
out of the lab and we still don't know
how to handle safely
this is where i think we actually want
to be proactive about thinking
but clever ways of handling it and it
might be that you want regulation
it might be that you want monitoring
systems it might also be
that you want to have a lot of people
doing experimentation so we figure out
some of the on the bad side
so early that the technology is not yet
mature enough to be dangerous
so i my utopia would be something like
in about about 100 years you have a
society where aging
is something that you read about in
history books and is regarded as
kind of a grave moral error of the past
why didn't people do something about it
why did people persist in that just like
sexism and slavery
this is a world where bodies are
something you select and design
where probably people show off with
their designer bodies especially the
bodies that are hard to maintain
because they show a real dedication this
is a world where you can get
intelligence on tap either
by connecting to machines or by having
very smart machines
do thinking for you this is a world
where
you have a lot of diversity and also a
lot of tolerance because
without that tolerance you can't
actually maintain a utopian world
you're going to have neighbors having
real trouble not just that they have
different religions
but different bodies and different kinds
of minds
and for that i think we need
transparency and accountability
but also a fair dose of practical
optimism they're going to
try a lot a thousand things and 999 of
them are going to be
hopeless failures some of them grew some
some of them
said so some of them i'm using but we
should learn from that
it's not like we can plan the future
it's not like we can have a technocratic
plan
that just points out we'll just do this
project
we're going to need a million projects
and learn from them
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you